I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. How do you everybody? Angela Kinsey here. It's Jenna and today we're talking about the convention. This season three, episode two. Written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stepnitsky. And directed by Ken Whittingham. Jenna, this was a really fun episode for me. I got to travel. I got to go on the road. I know. Remember last week we were talking all about how we got that
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一同出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为你录制专属的《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时身处其中的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妹。大家好，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我是珍娜，今天我们要聊的是“会议”这一集。这是第三季第二集。由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯泰普尼茨基编剧。肯·惠丁姆执导。珍娜，对我来说这集真的很有趣。我能去旅行了。我能出差了。我知道。还记得上周我们一直在谈论我们是如何获得
big season three bump so we could leave The Office and do things? Hello, we created an entire paper convention in episode two. We are going for it this season. All right. Well, let's get into this episode. I have a summary for you. I'm so excited. Here we go. I know. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks, babe. Babe, read me your summary, babe. Sweetie, here we go. Dolphys. Read your summary, Dolphys. Hey, Toots. I got a summary for you. Sweet cheeks. Read your summary, sweet cheeks. You know what? I might have just watched the Broadway HD 42nd Street. Oh, by the way, we watched that. Lee and I, we really miss life theater. We really miss it. It's one of our loves. And they have this great catalog of Broadway
第三季的大红大紫，所以我们可以离开办公室去干别的？天哪，我们在第二季里直接策划了一个完整的纸品展。这季我们真的是火力全开。好了。那么，让我们切入这一集吧。我为你准备了一个大纲。我太兴奋了。我们开始吧。我知道。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢，宝贝。宝贝，读一下你的大纲，宝贝。甜心，我们开始吧。杜尔菲斯。读一下你的大纲，杜尔菲斯。嘿，小甜心。我给你准备了个大纲。小可爱。读一下你的大纲，小可爱。你知道吗？我可能刚刚看了百老汇高清版的《第四十二街》。哦，顺便说一句，我们看了那个。李和我，我们真的很想念现场戏剧。我们真的很想念。这是我们的挚爱之一。他们有一个很棒的百老汇
shows on Broadway HD. And so we watched 42nd Street. It's so good. The woman who plays the lead, her name is Clara. And oh my God, she is mind blowing. The tap dancing this woman does is just insane. So anyway, but that show has a lot of like Toots, darling, babe, honey, because you know, it's all set back in the time. I don't know what time that was. What was that? The roaring twenties? When is the time? Roring twenties, probably. Yeah. All right. Anyway, summary. Summary. Listen, you watch your Broadway shows on the telly. I'm going to watch my humming birds. Yeah, this is what we're doing. This is what we're doing. Maybe I'll put on the
剧目库，就在百老汇高清（Broadway HD）。所以我们看了《第四十二街》。太棒了。演女主角的那个女人，她叫克拉拉。天哪，她简直惊为天人。这个女人跳的踢踏舞简直太疯狂了。所以总之，那部剧里有很多诸如“小甜心”、“亲爱的”、“宝贝”、“小宝贝”之类的称呼，因为你知道的，故事背景设定在那个时期。我不知道那是哪个时期。那是什么时候？咆哮的二十年代？那是哪个时期？大概是咆哮的二十年代吧。是啊。好吧。不管怎样，大纲。大纲。听着，你看你的百老汇电视节目。我要去看我的蜂鸟了。是的，这就是我们在做的事。这就是我们在做的事。也许我会调到
weather channel. I don't know anything could happen. Okay. Okay. Michael and Dwight traveled to Philadelphia to meet Jan, Jim and Josh for the North Eastern Mid-Market Office Supply Convention. Meanwhile, back in Dudder, Mifflin, Kelly sets up Pam on a date with her neighbor, Alan. He's a cartoonist. They're going to have so much in common, right? Yeah. But Angela sneaks off to surprise Dwight. Yeah. All right. Fast fact number one, we've got a big guest star, Robert Bagnell, who played Alan the cartoonist. Now you might recognize him because he also played Tom Peterman on HBO's The Comeback, starring Lisa Kudrow.
气象频道。我不知道，什么事都可能发生。好吧。好吧。迈克尔和德怀特前往费城会见简、吉姆和乔什，参加东北部中型市场办公用品展销会。与此同时，回到邓德米夫林，凯莉安排潘和她的邻居阿兰约会。他是个漫画家。他们会有很多共同点，对吧？是的。但安吉拉偷偷溜出去给德怀特一个惊喜。是的。好的。趣事一号，我们有一个重磅客串演员罗伯特·巴格内尔，他饰演了漫画家阿兰。现在你可能会认出他，因为他还饰演过丽莎·库卓主演的HBO剧集《喜感m!n星》（The Comeback）中的汤姆·彼得曼。
Did you watch that show? I did. I thought she was so funny. Well, the whole cast was phenomenal. I was obsessed with that show, obsessed. It is such an amazing satire of the entertainment industry and of an actress. There's a scene where she opens up a refrigerator and there's nothing in there except for seltzer water and these pre-packaged diet meals, and it made me laugh so hard. She's so self-obsessed and narcissistic and she plays it perfectly. Check it out, guys. It's amazing. And Robert Bagnell is on there. So I was so excited to get to work with him, but I knew him. How? We used to do this thing called Instant Films Together where they take these writers, directors, actors, and crew
你看过那部剧吗？我看过。我觉得她太搞笑了。嗯，整个演员阵容都太棒了。我曾对那部剧着迷，简直着迷。它对娱乐产业和女演员的讽刺简直太精彩了。有一个场景，她打开冰箱，里面除了苏打水和那些预包装的减肥餐之外什么也没有，这让我笑得前仰后合。她太自恋、太以自我为中心了，而她把这个角色演得完美无瑕。大家去看看吧。太棒了。罗伯特·巴格内尔就在里面。所以我特别兴奋能有机会和他合作，但我本来就认识他。怎么认识的？我们过去常常一起做一个叫“即兴电影”（Instant Films）的项目，他们会把这些编剧、导演、演员和剧组人员
and you get 48 hours to make a short film. You're randomly matched. You start at like 7 a.m. on Saturday with a little script that's been written for you. It's usually like four pages long and on Sunday night, everyone gets together and there's a little film festival. And it's so fun. Yeah, I have friends that did this and I don't know why I didn't participate, but I have friends that did this and loved it. Well, it's funny, Angie, because you're always kind of talking about how you did the groundlings or you did the sketch shows, improv a little bit. Improv festivals. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't do any of that stuff, but I did do these like short films, short film festivals, and then they do one for plays
召集起来，给你48小时时间拍一部短片。你们是随机组队的。通常从周六早上7点左右开始，拿着一小份为你写好的剧本。通常大约四页纸长，到了周日晚上，所有人聚在一起举办一个小型的电影节。真的非常有趣。是的，我有朋友做过这个，我不知道为什么我没有参加，但我有朋友做过这个而且非常喜欢。嗯，这很有趣，安吉拉，因为你总是喜欢提到你是怎么加入草台班子（The Groundlings）或者你是怎么演小品秀的，偶尔搞点即兴创作。即兴喜剧节。对。是的。我没有做过那些东西，但我确实做过这种短片、短片电影节，然后他们也会为戏剧举办这样的活动
as well. They do like a 24-hour play where you have to stage a mini play in 24 hours. So I would do like that kind of stuff, but I knew him from that. That's how I knew Robert. He was in the Instant Film World with me. Oh, wow. That's so cool. So I reached out to him and we had the best conversation about his time on the show and then he sent me like two pages of memories. Stop it. Yes. That's so fantastic. So kind, so generous. So he told me that the way he got the role on the show was through Mike Scherr. How? That Mike Scherr had been a writer on season one of The Comeback. Oh. And he had actually left The Comeback to go work on the office. I never knew that. Me either. Oh my God, I
他们会搞一种24小时戏剧，你必须在24小时内把一出微型戏剧搬上舞台。所以我就会做那种类型的东西，但我就是通过那个认识他的。这就是我认识罗伯特的方式。他曾和我在即兴电影的世界里共事。哦，哇。太酷了。所以我联系了他，我们进行了一次极其愉快的谈话，聊了他在这部剧里的经历，然后他给我发了两页的回忆录。别开玩笑了。真的。太棒了。人太好了，太慷慨了。所以他告诉我，他是通过迈克·舒尔拿到这个角色的。怎么拿到的？迈克·舒尔曾是《喜感m!n星》第一季的编剧。哦。而且他实际上是从《喜感m!n星》离职去《办公室》工作的。我从来不知道这件事。我也是。天哪，我
would totally have talked to him about that. That's so cool. I know. How did I not know to pepper Mike Scherr about come back questions? Yes. Lisa could wrote it, please. But here is the craziest thing about him. Do you want to hear this crazy personal connection? Okay. All right. Were you and him dating in college? No, I'm kidding. Go. No. No. But around the same time that he was guest starring on the office, he also had a role in a movie written by my now husband Lee Kirk. But we didn't know. Stop it. Yes. He was in this movie called Pants on Fire that was directed by Colin Campbell written by my husband Lee. And so it was like he was doing this scene with me on the office. And then he was shooting this role in Lee's
绝对会跟他聊聊这个的。太酷了。我知道。我怎么就没想到去缠着迈克·舒尔问关于《喜感m!n星》的问题呢？对啊。丽莎·库卓演的，拜托。但关于他最疯狂的事是这个。你想听这个疯狂的个人联系吗？好吧。好吧。你和他在大学里约会过吗？不，开玩笑的。说吧。没有。没有。但在他客串《办公室》的差不多同一时期，他还在一部由我现任丈夫李·库克编剧的电影里演了一个角色。但我们当时并不知道。别开玩笑了。真的。他演了这部由科林·坎贝尔导演、我丈夫李编剧的名为《谎话连篇》（Pants on Fire）的电影。所以这就好像他一方面在《办公室》里和我演对手戏。然后同时在拍李的
movie. And Lee and I weren't in love. We were not even a thing or knew each other on each other's radars. That is crazy. No. I know. Such a small world. That is so crazy. Yeah. Those are the little mind melt moments for me where your lives are crisscrossing and you don't even know it. So you and Lee had this existence crisscrossing and that's so wild. I love that. Well, the crazy thing is, is that movie Pants on Fire, that script was sent to me as a writing sample of Lee's. I was going to produce a movie and I needed a writer and I got Pants on Fire as the writing sample and I fell in love with it and I took a meeting with Lee. Oh my lord. And then he ended up writing a film for me called The
电影里的角色。而我和李当时根本没恋爱。我们甚至都不是一回事，也不在彼此的雷达范围内。太疯狂了。没有。我知道。世界真是太小了。太疯狂了。是的。对我来说，这就是那些让你觉得生活在不知不觉中交织在一起的小小灵光乍现的时刻。所以你和李有过这样交织的经历，真是太奇妙了。我太喜欢这个了。嗯，最疯狂的是，电影《谎话连篇》的那个剧本是作为李的写作样稿寄给我的。我当时正要制作一部电影，需要一个编剧，我收到了《谎话连篇》作为写作样稿，我一眼就爱上了它，然后我和李开了一次会。哦，天哪。最后他为我写了一部名叫《巨人机械人》（The Giant Mechanical Man）的电影，我和李就是这样坠入爱河的。太疯狂了。我们在《巨人机械人》中合作过，这部电影后来由李执导。哇。而罗伯特演了那部电影。罗伯特演了《谎话连篇》。这不疯狂吗？太疯狂了。我太喜欢了。好吧。所以不管怎样，我从罗伯特那儿得到了大量有趣的信息，等我们演到那些场景时，我会把它们穿插进去。好吧。那么，怎么回事？怎么回事？接下来是什么，女士？你的趣事。下一个。趣事二号。山姆，能给我一个粉丝提问的音效吗？什么？粉丝提问。这是一个粉丝提问，安吉拉。趣事二是一个粉丝提问。我得让我孩子们录点东西，然后我得把它发给山姆，我
Giant Mechanical Man and that is how Lee and I fell in love. That's so crazy. With that we worked together on Giant Mechanical Man, which Lee then directed. Wow. And Robert was in that movie. Robert was in Pants on Fire. Isn't that crazy? That is so crazy. I love that. All right. So anyway, I have a ton of fun information from Robert and I will sprinkle that in as we get to those scenes. Okay. So what's up? What's up? What's next, lady? With your fast, fast. Next. Fast fact number two. Sam, could I get a fan question? What? Fan question. It's a fan question, Angela. Fast fact two is a fan question. I only have got to get my kids recording some stuff and then I've got to send it over to Sam and I'm
下周会把它穿插进去。那是我女儿。那是我的女儿。太可爱了。太可爱了。嗯，你知道的，因为我儿子上周做了深度解析。所以这很好。这很好。她给我弄了一个粉丝提问的音效，因为趣事二号全是粉丝提问，从瑞安·阿普加开始。这个展销会是在哪里拍摄的？詹妮弗·伯曼。这是一个真正的酒店吗？他们不得不把整整几层楼或者整家酒店都包下来吗？莎拉·霍尔茨想知道，展销会上的那些摊位是真是假？关于这个展销会，有这么多的问题，安吉拉。是的。所以你知道的，我去查了安吉拉百科（Kentopedia）。安吉拉百科。我知道一两个，但肯特会有全部的内部消息。让我们听听吧。好吧。所以肯特告诉
going to sprinkle one in next week. That was my daughter. That's my daughter. It's so cute. It's so cute. Well, you know, because my son got to do the deep dive last week. So that's good. That's good. She gave me a fan question sting because fast fact number two is all fan questions starting with Ryan Apgar. Where was the convention filmed? Jennifer Berman. Was it an actual hotel? Did they have to completely rent out entire floors or the entire hotel? Sarah Holtz wants to know, were the vendors at the convention real or fake? So many questions about this convention, Angela. Yeah. So you know, I went to Kentopedia. Kentopedia. I know one or two of these, but Kent will have the full lowdown. So let's hear it. All right. So Kent told
我说我们是在伯班克希尔顿酒店拍摄的，现在它已经是一家不同的酒店了。它不叫伯班克希尔顿了。对。但它离得最近。如果记忆没错的话，它差不多就在伯班克机场附近。是的。是的。他说他们没有预订整家酒店，但他们确实预订了酒店里最大的会议室。而且他们不得不把那个房间预订整整一周，因为仅仅把它布置得看起来像个展销会就花了整整两天时间。所以他说他们从周一开始用各种展位和东西把里面填满。当我到那儿的时候，它看起来就像一个成熟的展销会。确实如此。所以肯特告诉我，他真的非常依赖他的制作团队。当他写信给我时，他说，请你一定要对这些家伙表示感谢，因为他们是
me that we filmed this at the Burbank Hilton Hotel, which is now a different hotel. It's not called the Burbank Hilton anymore. Right. But it's nearest. If memory serves, it's kind of over by the Burbank Airport. Yes. Yeah. He said they did not book the entire hotel, but they did book the largest convention room that the hotel had. And they had to book that room for the entire week because it took two full days just to set it up to look like a convention. So he said they started on Monday filling it with all the booths and all the stuff. When I got there, it looked like a full on convention. It really did. So Kent told me that he really leaned on his production staff. And when he wrote me, he said, will you please give these guys a shout out because they were
让这一切得以实现的功臣。安吉拉，我要给你抛出一些名字了。好吧。好吧。你还记得安吉拉·汉密尔顿和詹姆斯·凯里吗？记得。和肯特一起工作的？记得，当然记得。当然我记得他们。安吉拉是我们的联合制片人。詹姆斯·凯里是办公室经理。他说，在这个剧集计划拍摄前几周，他们就接到风声，说他们必须搞定一个会展。于是这两人联系了字面意义上数百家公司和企业，询问他们是否想参演这一集。交易是这样的。交易是他们必须自带会展物料。他们必须搭建自己的展位，提供自己的员工和服装，
instrumental in making this happen. Angela, I'm going to hit you with some names. Okay. Okay. Do you remember Angie Hamilton and James Carey? Yes. Who worked with Kent? Yes, of course. Of course, I remember them. Angie was our co-producer. James Carey was the office manager. He said they were tipped off a few weeks before this episode was set to film, that they were going to have to pull off a convention. So the two of them reached out to literally hundreds of corporations and businesses and asked if they wanted to be in the episode. And here was the deal. The deal was they had to bring their own convention materials. They had to set up their own booths, provide their own staff and wardrobe
好在剧集拍摄期间在里面撑场面。并且他们被告知，不能保证一定能获得出镜时间。但他们可以试一试，你知道的，他们当时说，我们会尽量让每个人都在镜头前出镜。他说他们找到了大量想要参与的人。这部剧现在太受欢迎了。人们简直是欣然参与。所以所有这些人，他说最后总共有176名所谓的群众演员、背景表演者，其中140人是实际公司的真正员工。这就是为什么它看起来那么真实。因为我想过，当我浏览的时候，我在想，这些看起来像真正的公司，他们的衬衫是配套的之类。就像那些我觉得对我们来说会很难搞定的细节，但那是因为它们是
to sort of populate them during the episode. And they were told that they could not promise that they would get screen time. But they could try, you know, they're like, we'll try to get everyone on camera. He said they got tons of people who wanted to participate. The show is now so popular. People weren't like delighted to participate. So all those people, he said in the end, there were 176 total quote unquote extras background performers and 140 of them were actual employees of actual companies. That's why it looks so real. Because I thought that I thought when I looked through it, I was like, these look like real companies and their shirts matched and things like that. Like details that I feel like would have been so hard for us to pull off, but it's because they were
真正的公司。我觉得这是你唯一能做到这一点的方法。我们的服装设计师凯里·班尼特绝不可能煞费苦心地为多家公司设计配套服装。是的，在两周时间内。我的意思是，这就是那种电影需要几个月筹备的工作，你知道的，而在电视行业，你必须在短短几周内把它搞定。所以他们就是这么做到的。太棒了。你知道的，詹姆斯太好了。我对他的印象太好了，因为我不知道。我觉得总有那么一些东西在我家里不太对劲。就像我在想，噢，詹姆斯，我本该把这个打印出来的。我的打印机没墨了，而我们一整天都在片场。所以这不是那种我们可以随便跑出去买打印机墨水或者跑去
actual companies. I feel like this is the only way you could have done that. There's no way that Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer, could have painstakingly designed matching wardrobes for multiple companies. Yeah, in two weeks time. I mean, this is the kind of stuff that movies have months of preparation for, you know, and in TV, you have to pull it off in just a matter of weeks. So that's how they did it. That's amazing. You know, James was so sweet. I have such fond memories of him because I don't know. I feel like there was always something that wasn't quite working at my house. Like I was like, oh, James, I was supposed to print this out. My printer was out of ink and we were on set all day. So it's not like we could just run and buy printer ink or run and
你知道的，无论我们需要做什么的时候。我会去那儿很多次，他会说，好吧，安吉拉，你需要什么？然后我说，你能帮我打印一下这个吗？因为我告诉过我妈妈，我要寄给她，而我的打印机。他总是随时准备帮忙。而且他们太棒了。安吉拉，我找到了我们剧组的一堆旧照片。看着它们我哭了。我只是，你知道的，每个人在看剧时看到的是演员。但我们在片场看到的是所有这些看着我们的其他面孔。看到这些我们的音响人员、灯光师、照明师、制片助理的照片，再次看到他们所有的面孔，简直是，哦天哪，安吉拉，太棒了。
you know, whatever it was we needed to do. And I would go in there so many times and he'd be like, all right, Angela, what do you need? And I'm like, can you print this for me? Because I told my mom, I'd mail it to her and my printer. He was just always there to help. And just they were amazing. Angela, I found a bunch of old photos of our crew. And I cried looking through them. I just, you know, it's, there's the thing that everybody sees when they're watching the show, which are the actors. But what we saw on the set were all these other faces looking back at us. And to see these pictures of our sound folks and our gaffers and our, our lighters and, and our PAs and to see all their faces again, it was just, oh my gosh, Angela, it was amazing.
好了，好了，我们进展到哪儿了，女士？趣事三号。这一集差点客串了一位麦肯齐·克鲁克的特别演出，他在英国版《办公室》里饰演了原版的类似德怀特的角色。是的，在BBC版本里。是的。是的。所以这是我在网上发现的一个小花絮，我记得是在邓德百科上，但我确实记得这个。所以如果我没记错的话，麦肯齐当时正在镇上为一部电影进行大型宣传巡回。我想那可能是其中一部，哦天哪，安吉拉，约翰尼·戴普演海盗的那部电影叫什么名字？哦，加勒比海盗。约翰尼·戴普演海盗的那部电影叫什么？我不知道。他差不多定居在加勒比海。是的。而他说，他就像是，优塞菲。优塞菲。我的继子杰克太
All right, all right, where are we at, lady? Fast fact number three. This episode almost featured a cameo by Mackenzie Crook, who played the original kind of Dwight in the British office. Yeah, on the BBC version. Yeah. Yeah. So this was a little nugget that I found on, I believe it was Dunderpedia, but I remember this. So I believe if memory serves, Mackenzie was in town doing a big press tour for a movie. I think it might have been one of the, oh my god, Angela, what's the name of that movie that Johnny Depp is in where he plays the pirate? Oh, Pirates of the Caribbean. What's that Johnny Depp movie where he plays a pirate? I don't know. He kind of said in the Caribbean. Yeah. And he's like, he's like, Yosefie. Yosefie. My Stepson Jack was so
沉迷于那些电影了，以至于有一年万圣节，他想当杰克·斯帕罗船长。我们给他买了一套完整的戏服。然后到了圣诞节那天，我们说，伙计们，你们想为圣诞节盛装打扮吗？我们给他们买了一套圣诞连体衣。杰克说，我能直接扮成杰克·斯帕罗船长吗？所以我们在圣诞树前拍下了这张搞笑的照片，伊莎贝尔和凯特穿着圣诞连体衣。他们看起来像个小精灵，你知道的，而杰克则是全套杰克·斯帕罗的打扮。好吧，你知道的，麦肯齐·克鲁克演了那些电影。我知道。是的。是的。是的。所以我想他当时正在镇上进行宣传巡回演出。他想让他在展位里短暂地出现在展销会上，和我们的德怀特聊聊天。这样两个不同的德怀特就能碰面了。
obsessed with those movies that one year for Halloween, he wanted to be Captain Jack Sparrow. We got him the full costume. And then on Christmas Day, we were like, guys, you want to dress up for Christmas? We bought them all like Christmas onesies. And Jack said, can I just dress as Captain Jack Sparrow? So we have this hilarious photo in front of the Christmas tree and Isabel and Cater in Christmas onesies. They look like an elf, you know, and Jack is full Jack Sparrow. Well, you know, Mackenzie Crook was in those movies. I know. Yes. Yes. Yeah. So I believe he was in town doing this press junket tour. He wanted to have him just appear at the convention in one of the booths and have a little chat with our Dwight. So the two kind of Dwights would meet.
那会太棒了。难道那不会很神奇吗？但后来档期对不上。他来不了。你知道当你进行宣传巡回时是什么感觉，特别是，我的意思是，我不知道为那么大体量的电影或那么大体量的剧集做宣传巡回是什么感觉，但他来不了。他想来，但他来不了。他人太好了。我见过他。他棒极了。但我知道，德怀特的会面差一点就发生了，但终究没有。珍娜，我太失望他没来了，因为我是他的超级粉丝。而且我喜欢格雷格总是试图融入BBC的演员阵容，我们确实见过他们好几次，但那会真的很酷。珍娜，非常感谢你带来的三个精彩趣事。也许我们该休息
That would have been so great. Wouldn't that have been amazing? But then the scheduling did not work out. He couldn't come. You know what that's like when you're doing a press junket, especially, I mean, I don't know what it's like to do a press junket for a movie that size or a series that size, but he couldn't come. He wanted to, he couldn't come. He's the nicest guy. I've met him. He's awesome. But I know almost almost a meeting of the Dwights almost happened, but did not. Jenna, I am so bummed he didn't come because I'm such a fan. And I love that Greg was always trying to incorporate the BBC cast and we, we got to meet them several times, but that would have been really cool. Jenna, thank you so much for three fantastic fast facts. Maybe we should take a
一下，然后回来继续看这一集。我喜欢，女士。我喜欢。好吧。我们回来了。潘坐在她的办公桌前，迈克尔走进来问：“嘿，你看到奥普拉了吗？因为我想当爸爸了。”而你说：“等等，等等，什么？奥普拉上面播了什么？”迈克尔看奥普拉最大的收获是，他得知安吉丽娜·朱莉领养了一个婴儿。所以现在他也想领养一个婴儿。是的。而且他想让潘赶紧行动。潘，快去行动吧。潘说：“我觉得你应该等一等，因为罗伊的姐姐研究过这个，光是申请费就要一千美元。”迈克尔说：“你就不能帮我找个便宜点的婴儿吗？”然后潘说：“嗯，而且这还需要很长时间，大概得八个月，真的。”就像八个月。
break and then we'll come back and get into this episode. I like it, lady. I like it. All right. And we are back. Pam is at her desk and Michael enters and says, Hey, did you see Oprah? Because I want to be a father. And you're like, wait, wait, what was on, what was on Oprah? Michael's big takeaway from watching Oprah is that he learns that Angelina Jolie has adopted a baby. So now he wants to adopt a baby. Yeah. And he wants Pam to get on it. Pam, get on it. And Pam's like, I think you should wait because Roy's sister looked into it and like the application alone cost a thousand dollars. And Michael's like, can't you find me a cheaper baby? And then she's like, well, also it takes a long time, like eight months, period. It's like eight months.
然后他说：“哦，天哪，我甚至不知道八个月后我还会不会想要一个婴儿。”史蒂夫对这一段的演绎真的太搞笑了。而你的反应太棒了。当你问“奥普拉上面播了什么”时，你的反应是：我好害怕。这是要走向何方？这到底要走向何方？好吧，最后，潘同意了，如果两人在30年内都没有孩子，她就会给迈克尔生个孩子。因为她觉得，我没办法，我摆脱不了这个。但我知道这以后会回来纠缠她的。所以在30年内，当你50岁的时候，你就要给他生个孩子。我会给他生个孩子。哦，天哪。没错。基本上就像我56岁的时候。好吧，那就这样吧。但你知道的，迈克尔会到处跟人说，他和潘已经同意生一个
And he's like, Oh my God, I don't even know if I'm going to want a baby in eight months. Steve's play on that was really funny. And your reaction was so good. Your reaction to when you say, what was on Oprah? I'm like, I'm scared. Where is this going? Where is this going? Well, in the end, Pam agrees that she will have Michael's baby if neither one of them have a baby in 30 years. Because she sees like, I can't, I'm not going to get out of this. But I know that's going to come back to haunt her. So in 30 years, when you're 50, you'll have his baby. I'll have his baby. Oh my gosh. Exactly. When I'm like 56, basically. Well, there you go. But you know, Michael's going to go around and tell people that he and Pam have agreed to have a
孩子了。你们会把“在30年内”这部分漏掉的。这段对话现在要开始纠缠她了。是的，肯定的。肯定的。他会告诉别人你们是彼此的备胎计划。是的。所以现在我们进入了真正的剧情，迈克尔，你知道的，正在打包行李准备第一次出行。他让瑞安帮忙。这是他的打包清单，对吧？为了这次展销会。三条裤子，三双袜子，三盒避孕套，三盒，时尚牛仔裤，三盒。珍娜，我不该这么做，但我深入研究了一盒里面有多少个避孕套。有多少？像一打吗？我的意思是，我觉得有个范围，但通常是36个。什么？一盒36个？我是在一个网站上看到的，也许那不是真的。我不知道。我不知道。我们要
baby. You guys are going to leave out the in 30 years part. This conversation is going to haunt her now. Yeah, for sure. For sure. He's going to tell people you guys are each other's backup plan. Yeah. So now we're in the actual episode and Michael, you know, is packing first trip. He has Ryan helping him. Here's his his packing list, right? For this convention. Three pairs of pants, three pairs of socks, three packs of condoms, three packs, fun jeans, three packs. Jenna, I shouldn't have, but I did a deep dive on how many condoms come in a pack. How many? Like a dozen? I mean, I feel like there's sort of a range, but normally it's like 36. What? 36 in a pack? That's what I saw on a website that maybe that's not true. I don't know. I don't know. Do we go
为此问问山姆吗？山姆，你想为一盒里面有多少个避孕套贡献点见解吗？好吧，我真的很感激你们总是把这种关于药物或性越轨的问题抛给我。我其实不知道这个。哦，好回答，山姆。好回答。好的。另外，话锋一转。迈克尔指出他还想带上他的时尚牛仔裤，为了让你们知道，时尚牛仔裤显然是白色牛仔裤。我想指出的是，他还在干洗他的牛仔裤。是的，我们在前面的一集里铺垫过这个，我很高兴这个梗得到了呼应。所以安吉拉进来了，她需要迈克尔签字领取他的每日津贴。我有两件事想指出。第一，珍娜，你看到我的高马尾有多俏皮了吗？看到了，我后来指出来了。
to Sam on this? Sam, do you want to contribute to how many packs are in how many condoms are in a pack? Well, I do appreciate you guys always throwing to me for drugs or sexual deviant things. I don't actually know this one. Oh, good answer, Sam. Good answer. Okay. Also, switching gears. Michael points out that he also wants to take his fun jeans, just so you guys know fun jeans apparently are white jeans. I'd like to point out he is still dry cleaning his jeans. Yes, we set that up in an earlier episode and I love that that got called back. So Angela comes in and she needs Michael to sign for his per diem. I have two things I want to point out. Number one, Jenna, did you see how sassy my ponytail is? Yes, I pointed it out later.
当你在茶水间时我注意到了。我其实把它写下来了。你想知道它为什么看起来是那样吗？为什么？嗯，这大约是整个艾美奖季、颁奖典礼季的开始。我们要去参加派对之类的活动，我做了一个高级的头发吹风造型。当我周一去上班时，我依然有着状态极佳的秀发。所以负责发型的金·费里把它扎成了这个马尾，它有着所有的波浪和质感。她当时说，我们就这样吧。安吉拉今天顶着一个俏皮的高马尾。所以之后她每天都得保持那个发型来连戏。但这就是为什么我有一个俏皮的马尾。我绝对百分之百注意到了。所以现在迈克尔有一段非常搞笑的单人访谈，但是珍娜，我有个问题要问你。这些是我们从未看到过的场景，
I noticed it when you are in the break room. I actually wrote it down. Do you want to know why it looks like that? Why? Well, this was around the beginning of the whole Emmy season, award show season. And we were going to parties and things and I had had a fancy hair blowout. And when I came to work on Monday, I still had great day to hair. So Kim Ferry, who did hair, put it up in this ponytail and it had all this wave and texture to it. And she was like, let's just go with it. Angela has a sassy ponytail. And so then she had to match that each day after. But that's why I have a fusted pony. I totally 100% noticed it. So now Michael has a very funny talking head, but Jenna, I have a question for you. These are these scenes that we never see,
那些从未被写进剧本的场景，我真希望它们发生过，因为在两分钟36秒的时候，迈克尔把乔什称为“穷人版的迈克尔·斯科特”。或者至少这是他在我的公寓周围人尽皆知的绰号。珍娜，他是在跟他的邻居和他的公寓单元里的人谈论乔什·ポーター吗？就像，他是在说，嗯，你知道的，穷人版的迈克尔·斯科特吗？他到底在多大程度上对他的邻居喋喋不休地谈论乔什·ポーター？有趣的是，我根本没听成那样。我听到的是，这可能是迈克尔在自己公寓的四壁之内，大声嘀咕给自己的话。哦，那就更悲哀了。是的，这就是他在迈克尔的公寓周围闻名的方式。在我的脑海里，我看到他，你知道的，在那个所有信箱都在的小墙壁旁。
that were never written, that I wish had happened because at two minutes, 36 seconds, Michael refers to Josh as the poor man's Michael Scott. Or at least that's how he's known around my condo. Jenna, is he talking about Josh Porter to his neighbors and his condo unit? Like, is he like, well, you know, poor man Michael Scott? Like, how much is he just jabbering away at his neighbors about Josh Porter? It's funny, I did not even hear it like that. I heard it as maybe something Michael has muttered out loud to himself within the walls of his own condo. Oh, that's even sadder. Yeah, that's how he's known around Michael's condo. In my mind, I saw him like, you know, at the little wall where all the mailboxes are.
他在开自己的信箱，有人走过来，然后他说：穷人版的迈克尔·斯科特。我觉得，他现在和吉姆是朋友了。而那个人说：哦，对，对，再见，迈克尔。好吧，抱歉，我就是觉得这个很好笑。好了，现在我们要转移到茶水间。安吉拉和德怀特，他们站在房间的两端。他们没有看着对方。安吉拉对德怀特要去这次旅行感到很不高兴，因为她真的很想和他在一起呆一会儿。但德怀特去这次旅行兴奋极了。作为助理区域经理，被纳入其中对他来说是一件大事。这就像是他工作的重要部分。安吉拉，你们俩站立的方式，你们俩不看对方的方式，真的让我觉得太搞笑了。你们的角色总是会这样
And he's opening his mailbox and someone walks up and he's like, poor man's Michael Scott. It's, I guess, friends with Jim now. And the person's like, yeah, yeah, okay, by Michael. All right, sorry, that just tickled me. Okay, so now we're going to move into the break room. Angela and Dwight, they're standing on opposite ends of the room. They are not looking at each other. Angela is upset that Dwight is going on this trip because she just really wants to spend time with him. But Dwight is so excited to go on this trip. It's a big deal for him to be included, assistant regional manager. This is like a big part of his job. Angela, it so tickles me how you guys are standing, how you guys aren't looking at each other. Your characters would do this all
做，就好像如果有人走进房间，不会对此感到困惑一样。现在，这可以说是办公室里经典的德怀特和安吉拉的时刻，我非常喜欢。关于这个有一个有趣的小花絮。这在互联网上可以查到，所以你可以读到它。但在围读剧本时，有一个不同的场景。我相信它是在围读剧本时。它没有进入拍摄剧本，在那场戏里我对德怀特要去感到很不高兴。所以那是一样的。德怀特和我在厨房里有这样一段对话，我对很不高兴。然后在最后，我说：我迟到了。这就像是一个悬念。我迟到了。是的。这就像是：什么？她怀孕了吗？是的。好吧，这个最终没有被拍摄。这没有发生。因为我认为珍娜
the time, as if people would not be confused by this if they walked in the room. Now, this is sort of a classic Dwight Angela moment within the office that I love so much. Here's a little interesting tidbit about this. And this is on the internet so you can read about it. But there was a different scene at the table read. I believe it was at the table read. It didn't make it into the shooting draft where I was upset with Dwight that he was going. So that was the same. And Dwight and I have this exchange in the kitchen where I'm upset with him. And then at the very end, I say, I'm late. And it's like this cliffhanger. I'm late. Yes. It's like, what? Is she pregnant? Yes. Okay, that did not end up getting shot. That did not happen. Because I think Jenna
一旦我们大声读出来，每个人都觉得：哦。我想格雷格当时大概觉得：等等，这，好吧，也许这太快了。这太快了，对吧？那会太疯狂了。如果在这集里，德怀特和安吉拉已经有了一个孩子，那会太疯狂了。而且你知道的，这会是对那次他以某种暗号询问她是否有处方药的时刻的一个诡异的回应，对吧？哦，是的。所以，总之，不用说，他们决定改变主意。安吉拉并没有迟到。她只是很不高兴，因为她想和他在一起待一会儿，我其实觉得这真的很甜。你多少能看到她较柔和的一面。然后我必须在这里提出这一点，这样它才讲得通。伙计们，我们还拍了其他
as soon as we read it out loud, everyone was like, oh, and I think Greg was like, wait, this is, okay, maybe this is too soon. This is too soon, right? That would have been crazy. That would have been crazy if in this episode Dwight and Angela are already having a baby. And you know, it would have been a weird sort of callback to that time when he asked her sort of in code if she was had any prescriptions, right? Oh yeah. So anyway, needless to say, they decided to change their minds. Angela was not late. She was just upset because she wanted to spend some time with him, which I actually think is really sweet. You sort of get to see the softer side to her. And then I have to bring this up here because so it will make sense. You guys, there are other
场景，解释了安吉拉最终是如何到达酒店的，但它们都在删减片段里。是的。这里有一个完整的额外情节，德怀特，德怀特偷偷给了你一张去见他的火车票。是的。我知道。他在离开前给了她那个。但在茶水间里，我必须跟你们分享我们背靠背的这个设定，我在饮水机旁，他在自动售货机旁。我们尝试了几个不同的位置，这是我们最终定下来的一个，但我们真的觉得太搞笑了。我们在这一场里笑得厉害。只是觉得这太荒谬了。而且肯·惠丁姆真的很让我们自由发挥，让我们掌控停顿的时间，直到我说：你还在吗？是的。所以有时候我们会留下
scenes that we shot that explains how Angela ultimately ends up in the hotel, but they're in the deleted scenes. Yes. There's a whole sort of extra plot line here where Dwight, Dwight secretly gives you a ticket on the train to meet him. Yeah. I know. He gives her that before he leaves. But in the break room, I have to just share with you guys this setup of us back to back and me at the water cooler and him at the vending machines. We tried a few different positions and this is the one we settled on, but we got so tickled. We laughed so hard in the scene. Just say how absurd it was. And then also Ken Whittingham really let us play with how long our pause was until I said, are you still there? Yeah. And so there were times where we left a
大量的空间，而且我们不跟对方说话的时间越长，只是背靠背站着，我们就觉得越好笑。然后到了最后，珍娜，我很好奇，因为我知道你有剧本，但到了最后，我说：别拿我当猴耍。你简直迫不及待地想离开这儿了。A-R-M。然后我就气冲冲地走出去了。现在，我记得我是即兴发挥的。哦，是的。剧本里没有这个。嗯，当我重新看的时候，我真的觉得当我吐出A-R-M这个词时，我听到了我的口音。我觉得当你即兴发挥时，你的口音会更多地带出来。是的，就是这样。这就是我们茶水间的小秘密场景。而且安吉拉本来差点就要在这里怀上德怀特的孩子了。是的。在一个平行宇宙里。好的。所以现在我们来到你的单人访谈，安吉拉。好的。而这
ton of space and we, the longer we didn't say anything to each other, but stood back to back, the more tickled we got. And then at the very end, Jenna, I'm curious because I know you have the script, but at the very end, I say, don't monkey me. You can't wait to get out of here. A-R-M. And I just like walk out all mad. Now, I remember I improvised that. Oh, yeah. That's not in the script. Well, when I rewatched it, I really felt like I heard my accent when I said, A-R-M. I think when you improvised, your accent comes out a little bit more. Yeah. So there you have it. That's our little secret break room scene. And Angela was almost going to have Dwight's baby here. Yeah. In an alternate universe. Okay. So now we go to your talking head, Angela. Okay. And this
里有我最喜欢的台词之一，安吉拉。你说：在马丁家族，我们喜欢说“看起来就像有人坐了从费城开来的慢车”。然后你解释说，那是“去看看那个荡妇”的暗号。是的。我是。接着我说：这里怎么会有苍蝇？是的。我们收到了一条来自科迪·戈尔德的关于你的单人访谈的粉丝提问。在安吉拉的单人访谈中，她拍打着一只苍蝇。那是剧本里写好的，还是有另一只虫子像在《火灾》那一集里一样骚扰了安吉拉？首先，科迪，我们很喜欢你呼应了《火灾》那一集里的那只虫子。安吉拉，这到底是怎么回事？我不知道。我不知道我和飞虫之间到底是怎麼回事。说真的。但因为我其实也在纳闷这个。我有拍摄剧本。我没看到任何关于苍蝇的内容。好吧。所以珍娜，
has one of my favorite lines, Angela. You say, in the Martin family, we like to say looks like someone took the slow train from Philly. And you explain that that's code for checkout the slut. Yeah. I am. And then I say, why are there flies in here? Yes. We have a fan question from Cody Gold about your talking head. In Angela's talking head, she swats at a fly. Was that scripted or did another bug harass Angela like in the episode, the fire? First of all, Cody, we love that you called back the bug from the fire episode. Angela, what is the deal? I don't know. I don't know what the deal is with me and flying bugs. Seriously. But I was because I was wondering about this too. I have the shooting draft. I didn't see anything about a fly. All right. So Jenna,
你还记得我们拍摄这一集的时候吗？天气热得疯狂。有一股疯狂的热浪。那是八月。因此，有所有这些类似于苍蝇的东西。我不知道你记不记得这个。哦，是的。简直是一场苍蝇泛滥。我想它们进来是为了避暑。我想它们也是。我想我们开门的时候。苍蝇们大概觉得：外面超级热。是的。苍蝇们就会想：哦，有空调。我要进那儿去。所以这个单人访谈，我们是那天午饭后马上拍的。而且你知道的，每当我们要吃午饭时，珍娜，他们会把门开得更久一点。是的。为了给它通通风。在我做这个单人访谈的全程中，大概有五六只这样的家伙一直在我的脑袋周围嗡嗡叫。
do you remember when we were filming this episode? It was insanely hot. There was this crazy heat wave. It was in August. And as a result, there were all of these like flies. I don't know if you remember this. Oh, yeah. It was like a fly infestation. I think they were coming in to get out of the heat. I think they were too. I think we'd open the door. The flies were like, it's super hot out. Yeah. The flies were like, oh, air conditioning. I'm getting in there. So this talking head, we filmed it right after lunch that day. And you know, whenever we would have lunch, Jenna, they would leave the doors open longer. Yeah. To kind of air it out. And there were like five or six of these dudes buzzing around my head the whole time I was doing this talking head.
所以有一次我一边保持着角色状态，一边随手拍打了一只。而吉恩，我们的编剧，当时和我同处一室，这把逗乐了。他太喜欢了。并且他说：安吉，你愿意，你愿意再拍打几只苍蝇吗？我说：好吧。所以我就又拍了一次。但这一次我即兴发挥了一句台词：这里怎么会有苍蝇？然后我们又拍了一条，我拍打得更多了，并且我即兴发挥说，你知道吗，这全怪凯文。他带了气味难闻的外卖。我还针对凯文吸引苍蝇的食物做了一整段非常尖酸刻薄的即兴发挥。那段没有剪进去。但我的另一句即兴台词进去了。天哪。太棒了。但事情是这样的，安吉拉，我得告诉你，剧本里的你的单人访谈内容和这一集里呈现的完全不一样。我查过。
So one time I just swatted at one while staying in character. And Jean, our writer, was in the room with me and that cracked him up. He loved it. And he was like, Ang, will you, will you swat at flies again? And I was like, okay. So I did it again. But this time I ad-libbed the line. Why are there flies in here? And then we did another take and I swatted more and I ad-libbed that, you know what, this is all Kevin's fault. He had smelly takeout. And I did this whole, really mean riff on Kevin's food that attracted the flies. That did not make it in. But my other improv line did. Oh my God. That is amazing. But here's the thing, Angela, I'll have you know, none of your talking head that is in the script is the same as the episode. I looked it up.
什么？所以“从费城开来的慢车”不在剧本里？“从费城开来的慢车”也不在剧本里。苍蝇不在剧本里。“从费城开来的慢车”不在剧本里。以下才是你的单人访谈原本应该有的内容。哦，天哪。是的。来吧，我想听听。内容是这样的。是的。迈克尔和德怀特·舒尔要一起去费城参加一个会展。就个人而言，我甚至觉得“会展”这个概念本身就令人反感。所有那些来自不同地方的人聚在一起，彼此呼出热气。这太恶心了。你喜欢我模仿安吉拉·马丁来读这段的尝试吗？我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我记得我们在做这个单人访谈时，吉恩和李递给我一页备选台词，珍娜。我有一大串备选台词。我们把它叫作“糖果袋”，你还记得吗？
What? So the slow train from Philly isn't in the script? Slow train from Philly is not in the script either. Fly is not in the script. Slow train from Philly not in the script. Here is what your talking head was supposed to be. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Here, I want to hear it. Here it is. Yes. Michael and Dwight Schrute are going to a convention in Philadelphia. Personally, I find even the idea of a convention repulsive. All those people from different places gathered together, breathing hot breath all over each other. It's disgusting. Did you like my attempt to read it as Angela Martin? I loved it. I loved it. I remember when we were doing this talking head, Jane and Lee handed me a page of alts, Jenna. I had a huge alt list. We called it the candy bag, you remember.
哦，是的。是的。不，当我们做单人访谈时，我们会先拍剧本里的那版，但一旦我们在椅子上坐下，他们就会递给我们写满备选单人访谈的纸页。有时备选台词会进入正片，有时则是剧本里的版本。没错。而这就是一个完美的例子。李和吉恩，我们这一集的编剧，给了我一页备选台词。很显然，“从费城开来的慢车”胜出了。大家都喜欢那个。关于苍蝇的那句台词是我即兴发挥的，因为苍蝇在拍摄全程确实一直在我的脑袋周围嗡嗡飞。这就是我们得到这个单人访谈的经过。科迪，我们太喜欢你的问题了。所以现在凯莉走向潘的办公桌。伙计们，她简直完全进入了明迪状态。她非常兴奋，因为她给潘安排了和她的邻居阿兰的约会。
Oh yeah. Yeah. No, when we would do our talking heads, we would have the one that was in the script, but then as soon as we sat down in the chair, they would hand us pages of alternate talking heads. And sometimes the alternates made it in the show and sometimes it was the scripted version. Exactly. And this is the perfect example of that. Lee and Jean, our writers from this episode, gave me a page of alts. Clearly, slow train from Philly won. Everyone loved that. I improvised the line about the flies because flies were literally buzzing my head the whole time. And that's how we got this talking head. Cody, we loved your question. So now Kelly comes up to Pam's desk. Guys, she's full Mindy. She's very excited because she has set up Pam with her neighbor, Alan.
是的。我本来打算播放我的音效，听起来像这样。完全进入明迪状态。是的，你得把你的音效用上，安吉拉。我有几个。我为这一集准备了好几个。你得把你的用上。当我说“播放我的音效”时，其实只有我在配音。并没有什么按钮。我没有按什么按钮。嗯，潘有一段单人访谈，在其中她解释说阿兰是当地报社的漫画家。他喜欢画画。她有点紧张，因为她已经九年没有过第一次约会了。然后她说“我大概不应该把这个广播出去”。我不知道为什么，珍娜。潘会说“广播”这个词真的让我觉得很好笑。就像，真的吗？我不知道为什么。这听起来像是一个非常老派的词。别把它广播出去。我不知道。
Yes. I was going to play my sting, which sounds like this. Full Mindy. Yeah, you got to get your stings in, Angela. I've got a few. I got a few for this episode. You got to get yours in. When I say play my sting, it's just me doing it. There's no button. I'm not hitting a button. Well, Pam has this talking head where she explains that Alan is a cartoonist for the local paper. He likes to draw. She's kind of nervous because she has not been on a first date in nine years. And then she says probably shouldn't broadcast that. And I don't know why, Jenna. It just tickled me that Pam would say broadcast. Like really? I don't know why. It just seemed like such like an old lady term. Don't broadcast it. I don't know.
当然，迈克尔现在正要动身去费城，他无意中听到潘要去约会。凯莉告诉潘不要在第一次约会上和阿兰发生性关系，但迈克尔告诉潘她应该把衬衫领口稍微解开一点。让那些家伙透透气。他是不是说了类似这样的话？让它们透透气。他总是希望它们透透气或者解放它们。他非常关心你的双乳受到束缚。所以有人写信进来，想问迈克尔和德怀特离开办公室时的那种歌舞表演到底是剧本写的，还是那两个家伙自己编出来的，那是他们完全自己编的。那是他们完全自己编的。在他们对她的说法表示不满之后，有一个舞台说明。然后上面只写着他们都笑了
Well, of course, Michael is leaving now for Philadelphia and he overhears that Pam is going on this date. And Kelly tells Pam not to sleep with Alan on the first date, but Michael tells Pam that she should unbutton her blouse a little bit. Let those guys breathe. Doesn't he say something like that? Let them breathe. He's always wanting them to breathe or set them free. He's very concerned about your tautas being confined. So people wrote in and wanted to know if the sort of like song and dance of Michael and Dwight as they're leaving the office, if that was scripted, or if those guys just made that up, they totally made that up. They totally made that up. There is a stage direction after they give her grief for saying. And then it just says they both laugh
然后走出门去。是的。所以所有那些出门的戏码，绝对是他们在自娱自乐。嗯，关于这一集我记忆犹新的一件事是，一旦我到了我们拍摄的酒店，那两个家伙就像是掉进糖果罐里的孩子。他们玩得太开心了，一直在互相抛梗。而且我觉得当他们聚在一起时，尤其是约翰、雷恩和史蒂夫，他们真的会变得兴高采烈。在展销会上有很多即兴发挥。我们待会儿会讲到。不过，是的，你是对的。你是对的。好了，现在安吉拉，我们在厨房里有这样一场戏。克里德走到你面前，问你他怎么才能弄到一点那种每日津贴的钱。是的。然后梅雷迪斯发表了一个评论，
and walk out the door. Yes. So that whole that whole out the door business, that was them having fun for sure. Well, one of the things I really remember about this episode, once I got to the hotel where we were filming is those guys were like, they were like kids in the candy jar. They were having so much fun, just all riffing off each other. And I think they really did when they would get together, especially John, Rain and Steve, they would just get giddy. There is so much improvisation that happens at the convention. We will get there. But yes, you're right. You're right. All right. So now Angela, we have this scene in the kitchen. Creed comes up to you and he asks you how he can get a little of that per diem money. Yeah. Right. So then Meredith makes a comment
说整个费城都弥漫着牛排三明治的气味。不管出于什么原因，安吉拉，你对此感到非常被冒犯。是的，我说那个小镇充满了历史。然后我站起来气冲冲地走了，留下了我的食物，珍娜。山姆，能给我我的音效吗？哦，天哪。牛肉在哪里？牛肉在哪里？牛肉在哪里？我来告诉你牛肉在哪里，安吉拉。你对我有意见吗？我有意见，而且不止我一个。哦，天哪。梅根·凯勒写信来说，不是一个问题。但是在《辣妹播客》（Hot Girl Podcast）中，当潘起身离开午餐，而罗伊说如果他没和潘约定时他就会约凯蒂出去时，安吉拉笑了。但在4分钟55秒时，安吉拉气冲冲地离开她的麦片粥。她就那样气冲冲地离开了她的食物。莎拉·德纳森说，珍娜，你能否请
that the whole town of Philadelphia just smells like cheesesteaks. And for whatever reason, Angela, you are very offended by this. Yes, I say that town is full of history. And I get up and I storm out and I leave my food, Jenna. Sam, can I get my sting? Oh, good God. Where's the beef? Where's the beef? Where's the beef? I'll tell you where the beef is, Angela. You have a beef with me? I have a beef and I'm not the only one. Oh, my Lord. Megan Keller wrote in to say, not a question. But in the hot girl podcast, Angela laughed when Pam got up and left her lunch when Roy says if he wasn't dating Pam, he would ask Katie out. But at four minutes, 55 seconds, Angela walks away from her cereal. She just stormed away from her food. Sarah Donaldson says, Jenna, can you please give
整个费城闻起来都像是费城牛肉三芝士三明治。不管出于什么原因，安吉拉，你对此非常生气。是的，我说那座镇上到处都是历史。然后我站起来，气冲冲地离开，丢下了我的食物，珍娜。萨姆，我能拿到我的刺痛吗？哦，天哪。牛肉在哪？牛肉在哪？牛肉在哪？我来告诉你牛肉在哪，安吉拉。你对我有意见吗？我确实有意见，而且不只我一个人。哦，天哪。梅根·凯勒写信来说，这不是一个问题。但是在火辣女孩播客中，安吉拉笑了，因为当罗伊说如果他没有和帕姆约会，他就会约凯蒂出去时，帕姆却站起来离开了她的午餐。但在第四分五十五秒，安吉拉却走开了她的麦片。她就这样气冲冲地离开了她的食物。萨拉·唐纳森说，珍娜，你能请给
Angela some what's for after the hard time she gave Pam for storming off and leaving her plate of food when Angela does the same thing at four minutes, 55 seconds. All right, Angela, I have a beef. Fine, fine. Okay, fine. I get it. I get it. Apparently on this show, if you get ticked off enough at someone, you just get up and you leave your food. Fine. Okay, fine. I'm sorry, everybody. I am sorry. My character does it too. I apologize. I apologize. But let me just say in the moment when you were taping that scene, did you stop and say, guys, I'm so sorry. This isn't realistic. I would never just storm away and leave my cereal here. But you actually had to leave your cereal there because Creed's going to start eating it. Creed is going to start eating it, which is hilarious.
And then he has one of his all time favorite lines. He has told me this is one of his favorite lines from the whole series. That's Andrea, the office bitch. You'll get used to her. And then he introduces himself to Merida. Exactly. Exactly. And then I have to point out my character, she's sort of being a hypocrite because earlier she's like, well, you know, Code for Slut is like someone who looks like they took the slow train to Philly. So Philly is like not a good place. But then here she's like, it's full of history. All right, now it's five minutes, 10 seconds. And Dwight and Michael are on the train. They are headed to Philadelphia. That's right. Michael has his headphones on. He has Dwight's neck pillow,
which he pretends he can't hear Dwight asking for. I have some fun facts about this. On Dunderpedia, it says that there is no passenger rail service between Scranton and Philadelphia. And maybe that was true back in the day when we shot this. But today I looked it up. Amtrak does offer two trains per day. Takes about three hours to get to Philadelphia from Scranton by train and tickets start at $41. Well, I would think that there would be a train. That makes sense. It does. So yeah. So now there is a train. I went to Kentopedia because I was fascinated by the fact that we shot on an actual Amtrak train because we did. That was not like some fancy weird green screen thing happening. That was a train. So here's what Kent told me,
Ange. What? I want to hear it. They let us shoot on the train for free. For free? Yes. But we had to agree that we would not disrupt their schedule in any way. So on day two of filming, while the set dressers and the production designers were setting up the hotel room at the convention, Steve and Rain and a very small crew with about five extras, they loaded into vans and they drove to the Seami Valley train station. They boarded the caboose car at 10.30 a.m. They were given the caboose car all to themselves. They got settled. The train started moving. Kent said they got their first shot off at 11.03. Then when the train arrived at the Burbank Airport station at 11.27, they got off the train and there were vans waiting to pick them up and take them back to our main
set. And that's how we got that train stuff. Isn't that same? I love that. What like specific details that Kent like gave you is amazing. Kentopedia, you are amazing. One of the reasons why Kent and I are friends is because I so fully appreciate the detail that he has kept in a way that I'm not sure many other people would. I know you do. I'm like, Kent and I are of a similar mind with our spreadsheets in order. We love it. Well, you guys, there are some other deleted scenes from the train that are really funny. So you go to the DVD set. If you have them, they're funny. All right. Well, then they're going to arrive in Philly. They're going to greet Josh and Jim. They're reunited. They're reunited. Dwight and Michael and Josh and Jim. I have a little bit
of a background catch. Oh, give it. All right. At five minutes, 34 seconds, Dwight is wearing his name tag. You know, they have these lanyards around their neck, right? Yeah. Dwight is wearing his and then at five minutes, 59 seconds, he's putting it on and it's got all this writing on it. Like he's got all of his phone numbers in Sharpie. He's got his cell phone, his home, his pager. He's got his room number, 556 on there. And he has written in a little assistant. He wrote in a little arrow. So it's like assistant to the regional manager. He like changed his like title. Oh my gosh, that is amazing. So they're all reunited now at the convention. And this was calculated. They knew that they needed to keep Jim and Pam apart by sending Jim to Stanford,
but they did not want to keep Jim from interacting with Dwight and Michael. So that was kind of the reason for this whole episode was to get Jim back in the world with these other characters, but still separate him from Pam, who is back at the office dealing with her own stuff. All right. I have two things, Jenna, that I think will be kind of fun that we clock. We like to track things guys at six minutes, 15 seconds. Oh, there's a good, good example of Jim saying Dwight. Oh, there's a Dwight. Yes, Jim has a talking head and John says Dwight. It's like, it's huge. So there you go. I love to track it when he says Dwight. And then back in the office at six minutes, 31 seconds. Well, some big information is revealed to Toby about Pam.
Yeah. Jenna, what? You are now, Pam is like the, the hot new meat in the office. Yeah, she's back on the market. Kevin, Kevin says that if he wasn't engaged, he would quote, so hit that. Kevin. Gross. Guess what I wrote down. Track in the perv. Track in the Kevin. You're tracking the Kevin perv. This is Kevin perv. It's not true. 31 seconds, Kevin perv. But the look that Paul Leverstein does as Toby, that look is gold. Oh my gosh, Toby has it so bad for Pam. I know. I know. And then Pam is in the kitchen and she's reading some of Alan's cartoons. Her, her blind date, Alan. I'm sorry. Is, is Pam prepping for her date? Jenna, is this a little bit of Jenna and Pam? Like,
oh, I have a date with this person. I'm going a deep dive. Is Pam doing a deep dive? I don't know if reading his cartoons on the page. She's taking an interest. She hasn't been on a date in nine years. She's trying to, she's doing her due diligence. And Kelly enters and she gushes about how smart his cartoons are that she doesn't even understand them sometimes. And then Toby walks in the kitchen and he kind of tries to get Pam's attention. But no, she's not clocking Toby. It just, when I watched him try to, he tries to wave. She doesn't notice. Then he goes in the bathroom. The track that I could hear was totally. It's like the sad scene from like peanuts. All right. Well, then we go back to the convention and Michael and Dwight are setting up their hotel
room. They've got a mini dartboard. They've got some booze. And Michael has strategically asked for and chosen a room close to the elevator because he thinks that he'll get more foot traffic that way. Yeah. He thought about it and he knows. Hopefully it wasn't by the service elevator. Yeah. This is true. Who wants the room by the elevator, Michael? But he's ready for, you know, he's ready to party Jenna. Because there ain't no party like a Scranton party because a Scranton party don't stop. What? What? Ain't no party like a Scranton party because Scranton party don't stop. What? What? You know it. Jim and Josh come by and they think that they should get to their meeting with Jan. Yeah. Right. I mean, they are here to work. They're here to work. But Michael is like,
come on, you've got time for shots. And then Jim and Josh have an inside joke. A shot of Midori. Jim and Josh have this inside joke and they start cracking up. And then Michael and Dwight so desperately want to be a part of this. They start laughing really hard, like too hard. Yeah. They have no idea what they're laughing at. And it's so embarrassing when Jim's like, no, actually is an inside joke. Yeah. You would not actually laugh at that. You don't know what we're talking about. And then Michael has that sad, sad line that he loves inside jokes and he's always wanted to be a part of one. Yeah. I wish I was. I love inside jokes. I'd love to be a part of one someday. Now, I want to point something out here. What? Michael and Dwight are wearing
matching gray Dunder Mifflin shirts. And then Jim and Josh are wearing kind of matching light colored shirts. They're wearing white and downs. Well, one of them has like a slight pink hue to it. And I feel like Johns has a slight yellow hue to it. Maybe that's just my computer monitor because I watched this on my computer. They were not exactly matching to me, which actually I felt like made it even cooler because they're like, you know what, just any light colored button down will do. Just make it a light color. Cream off white, white, light pink, light yellow, anything. They are strategically unbuttoned at the exact same place. Maybe that's just where all men unbutton their shirts, but I found it a little odd. I don't know. Check it out. But
I want to say something about those gray Dunder Mifflin shirts that Dwight and Michael are wearing. Okay. After this episode, I went to Carrie Bennett and I asked if she had any extras and she gave me one and I sent it to my dad. Oh, now this was before you could buy them. This was before Dunder Mifflin merchandise was out there and he used to wear it around. He was an engineer, a plastics engineer and he went on the road a lot and he would have to visit factories to help them with troubleshooting issues with their production line. Okay. So he traveled a lot and he would wear it when he traveled to these factories and people would say, oh, Dunder Mifflin paper company, what is that? And he would just, he would smile and he would
just say, oh, that's the company where my daughter works. Oh, look at your dad being coy, but so proud. That's so cute. But then some people would put it together and then he would be so excited and he would be like, oh, well, my daughter gave it to me. Oh, your daughter gave it to you. Where did she get it? Oh, she has an in. She, she's the receptionist there. And they would be like, wait, what? Yeah, he was so proud. My dad is so cute. My dad was the same way. He would, any photo from anything I was in, I mean, anything, he would either screen grab it or find a way to print it or get a copy of it. But he would always make the photo so big and he'd hang it on the wall and I would go home and there'd be a photo like Jenna of you and I
at some, you know, event, it'd be just like some little thing you and I were doing. There were photos with you. I don't know that I've ever shared this with you, but there are photos of you in my parents' home that my dad printed up. Jenna, you're like eight by eight by 12, 11 by 14. They're humongous photos of us on the wall. Oh my God, I love that. And you get it, right? Could you imagine if one of your kids was on a TV show? I feel like I would do the same thing. Oh yeah. I would collect everything. I would save everything. Parents are the best. Call your parents. Okay, so nine minutes, 13 seconds. Michael and Dwight are at the convention. There's some really great shots now of all the vendors and you really get a sense of how big this room was.
Michael is going around to all the booths and guys, he is really into swag. He's really into the freebies. He's got like a foam finger. He's, I don't know, some shirts, a lanyard or two, some sunglasses. He's got all kinds of stuff. I want to say this talking head is not in the script. Also, Jenna, at nine minutes, 12 seconds, we get to see a really fun cameo. It's Jerome Bettis. Yes, the bus. The bus. This was huge. Guys, to give you some context on Jerome Bettis, in case you don't know, Jerome Bettis is a former NFL halfback who played for the Rams when they were both in St. Louis and in Los Angeles. And he also played for the Pittsburgh Steelers. We shot this episode in August 2006. That February, the Pittsburgh Steelers won the
Super Bowl. Jerome Bettis retired after that game, like literally at the game, they won the Super Bowl. He gave an interview and was like, and now I'm retiring. So here's how this went down. I asked Kentopedia. Jerome Bettis had just been hired by NBC Sports as a commentator. And Angela, do you remember our NBC rep, Vernon Sanders? Of course, I love Vernon. Love Vernon. Vernon called Greg and Kent and said, what do you think about a little crossover thing here where Jerome Bettis does a cameo at the convention? Greg loved the idea and got together. They wrote a scene like on the fly, and then they shot it on day four of the shoot. It's so perfect too. It's so perfect that Michael would invite him to his party and then want him to commit to coming. Can I tell
people you're coming? So good. All right, so Jenna, I have a question for you since you have the script. As Dwight and Michael are walking away from Jerome, Dwight says, why do they call him the bus? And I swear I heard Michael say, because he doesn't like to fly. Yeah, that was scripted. That was scripted? That exchange was scripted. Yeah, his nickname was the bus. Yeah. And the reason his nickname was the bus was because he had this ability to keep running down the field while carrying other players on his back. Through people, basically. If you grabbed onto him, he could keep on going. He just kept going. Yes. But Michael thinks it's because he doesn't like to fly. Yes, exactly. Well, I just want to round this out by telling you guys a few things when
I was deep diving on Jerome Bettis. He seems like a super great guy. He was inducted into the Pro Football Hall of Fame in 2015, and he has the Jerome Bettis Bus Stop Here Foundation, which is dedicated to improving the overall quality of life for troubled and underprivileged inner city youth. And he has delivered over 1,000 pairs of cleats to children in the Detroit school system. So he's a good guy. Jerome, just so you know, if you ever hear this, we tried to figure out how to contact you, but we couldn't figure it out. We wanted to give you a little love and ask you a few questions, but we couldn't figure it out. So if Jenna slid into your DMs, no red flags, she was just wanting to talk to you about this episode. Oh, the number of DMs I've slid into
for this show, Angela. It's a lot. It's a lot. So now you're going to just see some wide shots of the convention and Michael walking around and he goes up to a Blackberry phone mascot, right? Yeah, he does. Someone in a Blackberry costume and he just starts messing with them and he even invites them to the party. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question from Rebecca Specter and Lauren Wood. They both want to know who was in the cell phone mascot costume. I want to know that too. Yeah. So there is some lore. There's some office lore. Okay. That it was Phil Shea. Well, that's what I thought. Yeah. I reached out to Phil. He said he was not in the Blackberry costume. He said he had a contact at R. A. M. Technology, which are the people who make Blackberry. And he got them to
send over someone from their company with the Blackberry costume and that's who it was. Well, it was an official. An official Blackberry. It wasn't us pretending to be the mascot person. It was the official mascot. Oh, that's right. Yeah. Okay. There you go. So should we go back to Dunder Mifflin and see Pam and Toby again? Should we visit Pam and Toby and Toby's awkward attempt to ask Pam out? Yeah. Oh, it's so sad. He walks up to her desk and she gets a phone call. And he waits and waits. And he loses his nerve. He can't do it. Now, while he's losing his nerve, did you notice that Paul drums his fingers on the reception desk? And remember when I told you guys that Paul would do this? He was a drummer. Oh, yeah. So here he
does it. He drums at reception while he's waiting for Pam. It's just something that Paul does naturally. So I don't even know that he really realized he was doing it. I know he was showing that Toby was nervous and anxious, but that movement that you see his hands do, he used to do all the time. Well, we had a couple of fans write in with a catch at 10 minutes, 35 seconds. What? Bailey Aspenson said, why are there the times and names of TV shows on a post-it note at reception? Oh, yeah. And Claudia Cano said there are two post-it notes on Pam's desk. One says seven to eight PM, Big Brother CBS, eight to nine PM, Animal Planet, Jane Goodall returns, A and E first 48 hours. And then there's a second post-it note, which reads facts, Jan, David and Connie. So she wrote,
my two questions are, are those a list of TV shows that Pam watches? And my second question is, who is Connie? So I looked at these. These are both in my handwriting. I don't know. I don't know who Connie is. I clearly just threw that in there as a little bit of, I don't know, spice. And guys, that was a list of the shows I was planning to watch that night. That's just a note to myself. Apparently, I remember being very much into Big Brother. And I guess I really wanted to make sure I didn't forget to watch this Animal Planet special on Jane Goodall. And then if I had time, I was going to watch some 48 hours. But you guys, just to know Jenna, she of course would write that down and write down the time and everything. It wouldn't just be like, Oh, I think I'm going to check these
out tonight. I will make a schedule of my evening. Here will be my viewing schedule for tonight. Well, I think this just tells you everything you need to know about me. I want a little trash TV. Yeah. I love animals. And then I do like a good mystery. Yeah, it really does say everything you need to know about you. I think that's a great night of TV personally. All right, lady. Well, why don't we take a break here? And when we come back, let's join Michael and Jim at the buffet. Oh, let's join them at the buffet. Yeah, you know, I love a buffet. We need a sting for that. All right, we are back. Jenna, I have a question for you. Okay. Who left the ham out? What? And why would you want a sandwich
when you went to bed? Huh, El McPherson? Huh? What are you talking about right now? I'm going to keep going. I'm going to wait to see when you get it. Oh, leaving the ham out for the bear was a joke. Oh, it's his birthday. Oh, surprise. What a bunch of assholes. Are you with me yet? No. El McPherson left a ham out. El McPherson is in bed and says, you know, I'd really like a sandwich. And then. Oh my, wait. No, you did not. I watched the edge. You didn't. Oh, I could cry. What did you think? I watched the edge. These were my comments right out of the gate. Okay. Right away as I start watching the movie. I'm not getting on that plane. Who's getting on that plane? What do you mean getting it? That did not look safe already.
Already. I'm anxious, Jenna. They're on this plane and now they're going to the middle of nowhere. And then they say, don't leave a hand. Don't leave food out. Then he's got to get up and make her a sandwich. And she left it. Someone left a ham out and there's a bear. And then they're like, surprise. And I'm like, they scared the crap out of me. And then I said, what a bunch of dicks. Those aren't good friends. I know the quote you love is what one man can do. What one man has done another can do. Do you know the one I love from this movie? What is it? There goes a guy with a plane. I have to say, I don't remember that. Come on. Robert says that a lot. And then what did Ellen MacPherson, what did her character have
like edged on his watch for all the nights? Okay. Listen, you didn't love the mental fortitude and gymnastics that it took for these two people who are kind of at odds to have to work together to survive the wilderness and a bear that was actively hunting them. Tracking them. Okay. I like the part when, when Anthony Hopkins, his character, Charles, as you know, because Alec Baldwin, who plays Robert will say Charles 300 times. When Charles is like, repeat after me, this bear is not going to kill us. The bear is not going to kill us. Yes. It's so good. It's so good. Angela, this is written by David Mamet, one of the all time great American playwrights.
I got that. It's a masterful work. I got it. I got it. I think it would be maybe better on the stage is what I'm going to say. How do you do this on the stage? I don't know. You have a person in a bear costume? I don't know. It's just the way his cadence is. Charles, Charles, Charles. Anyway, I about pooped myself when several times in this movie, it was so stressful. But you loved it. You loved the movie though, right? I didn't love it. I didn't love it. But I watched it for you. I don't ever need to watch it again. Also, they did so many stupid things. Like, like they would finally, you know, get a gun they could shoot the bear with and then one of them would like throw it in the pit
or like get the bullets out of it or they would, they were just like, none of the, none of these things that you're saying. Yes. At the end, at the end, I don't want to ruin it if anyone hasn't seen it. And I know we're going off on a long tangent. The bear is already dead at that point, Angela. Yeah. But now there's a man pointing a gun at you. And then when he falls in the pit, you like, or like, I don't need the gun. And then he's just going to keep trying to kill you, buddy. Okay. So anyway, okay. I don't, I don't know what to say. Anyway, anyway, listen, here's the thing. I watched it for you because you're my BFF. I now get it. I get it. I'm fascinated that this is a movie that you choose to watch every year. It makes me really fascinated
by you. I've always thought you're an interesting person. You're even more complex to me now. I might have to rewatch it one more time with you. So I can trash talk it. And if you want to do the same with me, if you want to pick a Game of Thrones episode and trash talk it with me, that's fine. You know, I wouldn't do that to you. I wouldn't do that to you because you love it. And I wouldn't do, I wouldn't trash talk something that you love. You would maybe, I just don't think I would. I think you would make some grunting noises and eye rolls. There'd be something. No, I would just, I would just mock you to others behind your back. Oh, vicious. Anyway, I'm kidding. You know, Angela sweetheart, you know, I would mock you to your
face. That's the kind of friendship we have. Sweetheart. I was trying to figure out how to bring up the edge to you and then I had watched it. I watched it three weeks ago and I've been trying to figure out where to bring it up. And then when all of a sudden Michael was at the buffet, I was like buffet, ham. Here's my in. I'm going to say who left the ham out. She'll get it right away. But it's so random. I get it. It's so random. Anyway, lady, I watched the edge for you. I think we're even for a bit. You watched one 90 minute movie. I watched three seasons of a television show. Okay, maybe. Okay, fine. Okay, I'm going to start Fleabag. Okay. Okay. Yes. Okay, watch Fleabag. Okay. Anyway, so we'll discuss back to the episode. Jim, he is desperately wanting to
ask Michael about Pam. Yeah. But he just can't even bring himself to ask about her. No, he asked about Toby. Yeah. And Michael's like, Toby is everything that's wrong with the paper business. Is that why you left? And all of a sudden Jenna, it all becomes clear to you that this whole time, Michael really took it personally that Jim left. And he's been trying to figure out why he thought it was because of him. And he he needs to know why Jim left his friend. Why would he leave me? Yeah. And then there's there's one, there's a little couple of lines here that made me laugh so hard. Jim, they're talking about Ryan. And Jim says, tell him I said hi. And Michael with all seriousness says, I will call him later with that message.
And I just picture, I just picture that Michael just keeps calling Ryan. Yes. Yes. And then they all start to sit down to eat lunch. And Michael, he just wants to impress everyone. He whips out that $100 bill per diem is like, here's the tip. Yes. And the bus boy is so excited. The bus boy is like, that's amazing. Right. Yes. And Jan is not impressed though, because she's just sort of like, you know, Michael, we're here for work. We're going to be in and out of meetings all day. You seem to think this is a party. So there's a little bit of tension here. I have a fun fact. I just wanted to point out that $100 bill that Michael pays with today. I looked it up. That would be worth $126 and three cents. Oh, Jenna. I just wanted to know the value of $100
bill that I know. I just wanted to know. And I could have let it go. I could have kept it to myself. You could have, but you couldn't. But I couldn't. You couldn't. So there it is. There it is. Well, then Jan says, I can't stay on top of you 24 seven. And Michael has a small nosebleed looking camera. So desperately wants to say that's what she said. But then Angela scandal. Who's been the big sunglasses? What is your character having all of these like weird incognito disguise hats and glasses in her closet? You're hilarious. You draw more attention to yourself than not. She's got a closet of hats and wigs and glasses. She's like on the Americans. Yes. She's got her rendezvous. And she's like, and of course, why did they use Jane Doe? That's so creepy.
Do you know Jane Doe? She narrowly avoids Michael. But she gets her key. She's checking in. Oh, oh, Jenna, we have to talk about this is the one moment in the whole episode that Jim and Pam hear each other. Jim and Pam, it's as close as they'll get to being together. And it's when Pam calls Michael and Jim overhears and he's like, Hey, I'm with Jim and try and Josh say hi. And Pam's like, Hi. And that's it. That's their only moment. But not only that, this is a layered moment because in this moment, not only did they hear each other's voices, but in this moment, Jim knows that now that Pam is single and Pam now knows that Jim knows because Michael wishes her good luck on your first date. Yeah. So Pam, Pam knows, Jim knows I'm single. You know, she was
hoping he would find out somehow. Yeah. Now he knows. He doesn't call. He doesn't call. He doesn't call him either. Why aren't they calling each other? I don't know. It's like the age of innocence. I guess that book made me crazy. I'm like, just be together already. All right. Well, then Michael has a talking head where he's kind of going off on Jim. He says, Jim and I, we have different definitions of friendship. Apparently Jim thinks friendship is moving to Stanford. So he's not going to talk to Jim anymore. He's had enough. He's like a jilted lover. He is so heartbroken. He is. Angela, we had a really great fan catch. You'll like it. It's from Claudia Cano. She said, there is a rubber ducky in two shots. There's one at 14 minutes,
56 seconds, which is in the background of this talking head. And then again at 19 minutes, 47 seconds. Did Michael travel with the rubber ducky or get it at the convention? Oh, that was a convention giveaway for sure. That's swag, baby. That's the swag. There it is. Underneath, like on the duck's belly, you can't see it. It probably says a paper company name. For sure. We're not quacking around. We're number one in colored paper. Exactly. The duck stops here. Angela, you are really good at these. Give me more. If you think of more, shout them out. No, I won't. Okay. Well, my favorite part of this talking head, Angela, is that we widened to reveal that Michael is actually having a drink with the
hammer mill rep. I know. This whole talking head has been delivered with another person in the room. I have a fun fact about the hammer mill rep. Okay. That was played by actor Matt Price. Angela, Matt Price screen tested for the role of Dwight. No, I screen tested with him. He was one of the people that I was paired with at the final audition. They loved him and Greg wanted a way to bring him back. And by the way, as we go through the series, a lot of the people who had final screen tests for main roles are brought back as guest stars throughout the show because Greg just loved them so much. I love that about Greg. I know. He doesn't forget people. If you impress him, he'll find a place for you. All right. So at 15 minutes, 42 seconds, Jim is now going to
prank Dwight. It's like old times, right? He got a key to his room and he is going to go in there and do something. All right. I have some stories about this day. Yes, because what happens when he opens the door? Angela, what does Jim find? A lady on the bed. He finds someone who he thinks is a hooker. But it's actually Angela. All right. Well, Angela, fan question from Aiva Earl. Angela, is that really your leg that we see in Dwight's hotel room? Yes, it's really my leg. And of course, they had a whole outfit picked out for me. I had to have a wardrobe fitting for it, even though you don't really see much. It was conservative. Sorry to disappoint. But it was a pink pajama top, long sleeve. And then I have these black polka dot pants, like pajama pants,
恶作剧德怀特。就像以前一样，对吧？他拿到了房间钥匙，准备进去做点什么。好的。我有一些关于这一天的故事。是的，因为当他开门时会发生什么？安吉拉，吉姆发现了什么？床上有个女人。他发现了一个他认为是妓女的人。但其实是安吉拉。好吧。那么，安吉拉，来自Aiva Earl的粉丝提问。安吉拉，我们在德怀特酒店房间里看到的真的是你的腿吗？是的，真的是我的腿。当然，他们为我挑选了一整套服装。我得试装，尽管其实看不到多少。很保守。抱歉让大家失望了。但那是一件粉红色的睡衣上衣，长袖的。然后我穿着这条黑色波点裤，就像睡裤一样，
but they were kind of satiny. Oh, that's the sexy part. Yes. And so you could see my calf when I raised my leg. And I had painted my toenails red. So there's that. But I had talked about this scene in an interview because I don't ever get any scenes with Jim. Jim and Angela rarely interact if you watch the whole show. Yeah. So John and I, as friends in real life, we were giddy. We were so excited to finally be in the scene together. And what you guys didn't see was when he opens the door, there's a mirror on the wall. And he sees my legs and he freaks out. But I could see his whole expression in the mirror. I could see everything. And his face when he saw my legs, every time John did the scene, he would do this range of reaction of like horror and just like
但有点像绸缎的。哦，那是性感的部分。是的。所以当我抬起腿时可以看到我的小脚肚。我把脚趾甲涂成了红色。就是这样。但我曾在一次采访中谈到过这场戏，因为我从来没有和吉姆一起拍过戏。如果你看整部剧，吉姆和安吉拉很少互动。是的。所以约翰和我，作为现实生活中的朋友，我们兴奋极了。我们太激动了，终于能一起演对手戏了。你们没看到的是，当他打开门时，墙上有一面镜子。他看到了我的腿，然后他吓坏了。但我能在镜子里看到他所有的表情。我什么都能看到。每当约翰拍这场戏时，当他看到我的腿，他就会做出那种恐惧和...
shock. And it was so funny. We were laughing so hard, trying not to ruin the takes. And then, of course, my character is like D. And they were debating on how much of me they were going to see. Yeah. Just my legs, to really sell it. Like how much did Jim see of me, right? Yeah. So we sort of played around with that a little bit. And then Jenna, I think this is the first time my character calls Dwight D. And we established that nickname. I think it is. Yeah. Yes. I don't know. We'll track it, guys. We'll track it. But I think this is the first time I call him D. Angela, I think we need to go on a double date now with Ryan, Kelly, Pam, and Alan. So cringy. Jenna, this scene was so awkward to watch. Yes. Kelly is force feeding Ryan some french fries with ketchup.
震惊的表情。太搞笑了。我们笑得太厉害了，极力忍住不笑场。然后，当然，我的角色就像D。他们当时在争论到底能让我露多少。是的。只有我的腿，为了更有说服力。就像吉姆到底看到了我多少，对吧？是的。所以我们稍微拿这个开玩笑了。然后珍娜，我想这是我的角色第一次叫德怀特为D。我们确立了这个外号。我想是的。是的。不知道。我们记着呢，伙计们。我们记着呢。但我想这是我第一次叫他D。安吉拉，我觉得我们现在得和瑞恩、凯利、帕姆和艾伦进行一次双约会了。太尴尬了。珍娜，这场戏看起来太尴尬了。是的。凯利正强行喂瑞恩吃沾了番茄酱的薯条。
She insists that he loves it. He loves ketchup. He loves it. And then Alan, I mean, Alan is just kind of cheesy, Jenna. He's just oh my gosh. Yes. Well, Robert told me that his favorite Alan line is people always say don't be edgy, but I don't know any other way. He was like, it was so pretentious. It said it was such great comic writing. He also told me that he still gets recognized as the freedom fries guy. And he's very grateful. Do people call him the freedom fries guy? Freedom fries guy. Hey, you're the freedom fries guy from the office. And he also told me this really sweet story. He said after we were done shooting, Mindy walked him out and just went on and on about how grateful she was to him for being on the show. And then she told him that while
她坚信他很喜欢。他喜欢番茄酱。他超爱。然后艾伦，我的意思是艾伦有点俗气，珍娜。他真是……哦天哪。是的。嗯，罗伯特告诉我他最喜欢的艾伦台词是“人们总是说不要剑走偏锋，但我不知道还能怎么做”。他当时就觉得，太做作了。他说这是非常棒的喜剧写作。他还告诉我，直到今天人们依然认得出他是“自由薯条男”。他非常感激。人们真的叫他“自由薯条男”吗？自由薯条男。嘿，你就是《办公室》里的那个自由薯条男。他还给我讲了一个非常温暖的故事。他说拍摄结束后，明迪送他出门，对他加入这部剧表达了无尽的感激。然后她告诉他，当
Alison was putting people on tape, because that's what she would do. Alison would hold auditions for parts and put people on tape. They had this idea that they might want to cast an SNL cast member in this role. And I'm not going to say who, but Mindy said we watched the tapes that Alison sent over and you were so funny that we ended up giving you the role instead of offering it to this SNL cast member. And Robert said it is still to this day. He wears that as like a badge. A badge of honor. Yeah, he was like, I can brag that I beat out an SNL cast member for a part on the office. So he just he was so sweet and so humble and so grateful and so excited to talk about this. Such a nice guy. He's great. Alright, well, speaking of our lives, Chris crossing with
爱丽森在录制试镜带的时候，因为她总是这样。爱丽森会为角色举行试镜并录制磁带。他们当时有个想法，可能想在剧里选一个SNL（周六夜现场）的演员来演这个角色。我不说是谁，但明迪说我们看了爱丽森发过来的磁带，你太搞笑了，所以我们最后把这个角色给了你，而不是那个SNL的演员。罗伯特说直到今天。他依然把这当成一种荣誉。荣誉的象征。是的，他说，我可以吹嘘说我在《办公室》里击败了一个SNL演员获得了这个角色。所以他真的很可爱、很谦逊、很感激，也很兴奋能谈论这一切。真是个好人。他人太好了。好吧，说到我们的人生与这些客串演员在16分37秒时的交集，
these guest stars at 16 minutes 37 seconds. Jenna, Michael gets the first guest to his party who doesn't stick around because no one's there and he's like awkward. But it's played by Steve Little. I noticed. I love Steve Little. You guys know he played Uncle Jim in the show I did on Netflix called Haters Back Off. It's it's based off Miranda Sings based off that character with Colleen Ballinger and Eric Stocklin and Francesca Rialet and Steve Little and I have maybe one of the most awkward romances, even more awkward than Dwight and Angela, you guys. I mean, we have a date and a bathtub. No, you think that a romance can't get weirder than Dwight and Angela until you watch Haters Back Off and see you and Steve Little for sure 100%. That man could read the phone book
珍娜，迈克尔迎来了派对的第一位客人，但他没呆多久就走了，因为现场没人，他觉得很尴尬。这个角色由史蒂夫·利特饰演。我注意到了。我超爱史蒂夫·利特。你们知道他在我在Netflix演的剧《讨厌的人退散》里演吉姆叔叔吗？那是根据柯林·白林杰和埃里克·斯托克林、弗兰西斯卡·雷亚莱的角色——也就是米兰达·辛斯改编的。我和史蒂夫·利特之间也许有最尴尬的罗曼史，甚至比德怀特和安吉拉还要尴尬，伙计们。我的意思是，我们在浴缸里约会。不，你会觉得罗曼史不可能比德怀特和安吉拉更诡异了，直到你看了《讨厌的人退散》，看到你和史蒂夫·利特，绝对百分之百。那个男人就算在读电话本
and I'd be cracking up. I'd be laughing so hard. He can. He is so funny. Just everything that comes out of his mouth made me laugh and we got to improvise a lot together and really create this creepy relationship and I just I just love him. I am a huge, huge Steve Little fan. Well, I worked with him on Haters Back Off but a lot of people knew him from Eastbound and Down as well as many other things. He's just a really great comedic actor. Well, so you know Pam's date did not go great. She says Alan was a bit of a dud, right? Yeah. It was not a love connection. She says she says she'll know it when she likes someone again. She already likes that person. She does. Then Jim gets off the elevator and discovers Michael is alone in his room with a strobe light
我也会捧腹大笑。我会笑得前仰后合。他真的可以。他太搞笑了。他嘴里说出的每一句话都让我发笑，我们一起即兴发挥了很多，真正创造了这种令人毛骨悚然的关系，我真的很喜欢他。我是史蒂夫·利特的超级超级粉丝。好吧，我和他在《讨厌的人退散》中合作过，但很多人也通过《东边跑西边走》以及许多其他作品认识了他。他真是一个非常出色的喜剧演员。好吧，你们知道帕姆的约会并不顺利。她说艾伦有点无趣，对吧？是的。这不是一段来电的感情。她说她只有在重新喜欢上某人时才会心动。她其实已经喜欢上那个人了。她确实喜欢。然后吉姆走出电梯，发现迈克尔独自一人呆在房间里，开着频闪灯
and some dance music. Really loud music. Like loud. I couldn't believe no one called and complained on him. The music was so loud. I know I'm 100 but I was like that's very loud. Well, Michael is really grouchy. We don't see Michael like this a lot. He's being super passive aggressive. It's Michael Sass. It's Michael Sass but I have a little bit of backstory guys. If you watch the deleted scenes, remember how he said there's some of the Dwight Angela stuff that plays out that got cut? Yeah. So you actually see Dwight is checking his watch. He's got to get to Angela in the room and he makes up a lame excuse and he leaves Michael alone in his hotel room and Michael's grumpy about that. He's grumpy because he feels like Jim has ditched him for Josh Porter. So there's
还有一些舞曲。音乐声音非常大。超级大。我简直不敢相信没有人打电话投诉他。音乐声音太大了。我知道我像个老古董，但我觉得声音真的太大了。好吧，迈克尔真的很暴躁。我们很少看到迈克尔这样。他表现得超级被动攻击。这就是迈克尔式的刻薄。这就是迈克尔式的刻薄，但我有个小背景故事，伙计们。如果你看删减片段，还记得他说有些德怀特和安吉拉的戏份被剪掉了吗？是的。所以你实际上会看到德怀特在看表。他得去房间找安吉拉，于是他找了个蹩脚的借口，把迈克尔一个人留在酒店房间里，迈克尔为此很不高兴。他很不高兴，因为他觉得吉姆为了乔什·波特抛弃了他。所以这里
a lot happening here. Michael feels kind of like his friends have abandoned him. This is also where Jim finally tells Michael, I did not leave because of you Michael. You were a great boss. I left because of Pam and Michael is kind of like, you did? That's crazy because Pam's single now. You can come back. Well, I also think I think he wants Jim to know that but he's also instantly relieved that it wasn't because of him and that his friend is still his friend. Yes. And Jim once again is sharing something incredibly personal with Michael. I know because Jim says, listen, man, I put it on the line for Pam twice and I got rejected twice. I'm just, I'm not going to, I'm not going to call her. I don't know. Like, and I think he has a good point.
发生了挺多事。迈克尔觉得自己的朋友抛弃了他。这也是吉姆最终告诉迈克尔的地方：“我离开不是因为你，迈克尔。你是个很棒的老板。我离开是因为帕姆。”迈克尔的反应大概是：“你走了？这太疯狂了，因为帕姆现在单身啊。你可以回来了。”嗯，我也觉得，我觉得他既想让吉姆知道这一点，但同时又瞬间松了一口气，因为离开不是因为他，而且他的朋友依然是他的朋友。是的。而且吉姆再次向迈克尔分享了极其私密的事情。我知道，因为吉姆说：“听着，伙计，我为了帕姆孤注一掷过两次，结果被拒绝了两次。我只是，我不会，我不会给她打电话的。我不知道。”而且我觉得他说得很有道理。
Like he made it clear. He smooched her in the office as she knows how he feels. He said, I love you. Yeah. He said, I love you. The ball is in her court. 100%. I totally get how he's like, if she called off the wedding and she didn't phone me, what am I supposed to do with that? I'm going to go be like, Hey, did you call off the wedding now? Can I have a chance? No. Jim's playing this right in my opinion. Yeah. So then at the end, the hammer mill reps show up for the party. This is so exciting. They have two guests and Michael tells them that he and Jim are best friends, best friends. So it ends up being a win for Michael because he gets his friend back. He makes a huge sale with hammer mill, right? Jan ultimately is impressed
就像他已经表明心迹了。他在办公室里吻过她，她知道他的感受。他说，“我爱你”。是的。他说，“我爱你”。球现在在帕姆那边。百分之百。我完全理解他为什么会想，如果她取消了婚礼却没有打电话给我，我该怎么处理？难道我要去说：“嘿，你现在取消婚礼了吗？我能有机会吗？”不。依我来看，吉姆的处理方式是对的。是的。所以最后，锤磨厂的代表们出现在派对上。这太令人兴奋了。他们有两个客人，迈克尔告诉他们，他和吉姆是最好的朋友，最好的朋友。所以这最终对迈克尔来说是一场胜利，因为他找回了他的朋友，而且他和锤磨厂做成了一笔大生意，对吧？简最终对迈克尔
with Michael as a salesman. He's not number two behind Josh Porter. So Michael has a nice ending here. He does. He goes through a lot at this convention, but in the end he wins. And we've got a very funny tag at the end of this episode. Michael and Dwight are in the hotel room. They turn off the lights because they're going to turn on a black light because it's a party. I guess for their party. Yeah. Yes. And there are just these splatters all over the room. And Dwight says, well, it's either blood, urine or semen. And I love Michael's line. He says, God, I hope it's urine. I hope it's urine. When do you ever hope it's urine? I think in that situation. This was a really fun episode. I had such a great time doing it. It was so fun
作为一个销售员的能力刮目相看。他不再是排在乔什·波特后面的老二了。所以迈克尔在这里有了一个美好的结局。确实如此。他在这次大会上经历了很多，但最后他赢了。在这集结尾，我们有一个非常搞笑的彩蛋。迈克尔和德怀特在酒店房间里。他们关掉了灯，因为他们要打开黑光灯，因为这是一场派对。我想是为他们的派对准备的。是的。是的。房间里到处都是这种飞溅的痕迹。德怀特说：“好吧，这要么是血、尿，或者是精液。”我太喜欢迈克尔的台词了。他说：“天哪，我希望那是尿。我希望那是尿。”你什么时候会希望那是尿啊？我想也就那种情况下吧。这真的是非常有趣的一集。我拍这一集的时候过得太开心了。真的太有趣了
to rewatch it again. I just remember laughing a lot. And that was a real joy for me this week. I hope you guys enjoyed it. I want to give a big shout out and a big thanks to Kent Sabornak for his Kentopedia facts and also to Robert Begnell for all his fun stories. You guys, you can follow Robert Begnell on his Instagram at Bobby underscore bagstagram. It's like Instagram, but it's bagstagram. Or you can find him on YouTube. He's got this amazing travel show called travel bags. He spent like the last five years traveling mostly through Southeast Asia. And he's been documenting his travels. He's turned them into these very watchable, fun, very addictive videos. I highly recommend. Anyway, big thanks to those guys. And we'll
重新看了一遍。我只记得自己笑了好多次。这对我这周来说简直是一大乐事。希望你们也喜欢。我要向肯·萨博纳克表达大大的敬意和感谢，感谢他的肯氏百科知识，还要感谢罗伯特·贝格内尔分享的所有有趣故事。伙计们，你们可以在Instagram上关注罗伯特·贝格内尔，账号是Bobby下划线bagstagram。就像Instagram，但叫bagstagram。或者你也可以在YouTube上找到他。他有一个超级棒的旅游节目叫《旅行包》。过去五年左右他一直在旅游，主要在东南亚。他一直在记录他的旅行。他把这些做成非常具有观赏性、有趣且让人上瘾的视频。强力推荐。总之，非常感谢这些伙计们。我们
see you next week for the cool. Thank you for listening to office ladies. Office ladies is produced by ear wolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of office ladies, go to Stitcher premium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher premium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周再见，继续我们的精彩旅程。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问Stitcher premium.com。在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码office。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。